take us to China give us from your
perspective as you said travel around
the world see all different companies
and governments what does it really look
like there you know again I feel like
I'm sound like Pangloss like I should be
more pessimistic and I was pretty
pessimistic in HO 7 China has had 20
years of 10% growth uninterrupted never
before seen in this planet as they go to
market reform which they're gonna have
to do and market reform is the
state-owned enterprises have to have
more transparency MERS become public
they need real bond markets real
collateral markets they got to reduce
corruption these are all kind of related
they're gonna have bumps in the road and
what happened in the summer is that they
showed that they're gonna have bumps in
the road and the growth isn't going to
be ten percent it might be six to seven
percent now remember 6% growth
unintentionally in dollar-plus economy
is six hundred billion dollars of growth
that's by a lot more than it was 15
years ago when it was ten percent growth
and you know six hundred billion is more
than most countries in this planet so
they have the wherewithal there's an
article of paper today they've got three
and a half trillion of foreign exchange
reserves mostly what I'd say
unencumbered they're they're quite
bright they move rapidly they have huge
issues you know but they're dealing with
their issues and you know we should work
with them to help them get through that
but they have huge issues I remind the
American public America has the greatest
military defense not just the best
military ever designed called the
Atlantic and the Pacific and we've got
friendly neighbors in Canada and Mexico
okay and we have all the food water and
energy we'll ever need China is
surrounded by some historical enemies I
mean our Americans may not know but
China had a war you know with Russia
battle skirmishes with Russia you know
there they got Japan Philippines North
Korea Pakistan India and they don't have
enough food water and energy they've got
huge issues you know it's gonna be a
long time before they overtake America
in any way shape or form